What we've seen so far, is capable of dealing with simple,
one-level architectures. However, humans deal with complexity using divide and
conquer, breaking things into smaller pieces and
then trying to put them together somehow. For software architecture descriptions
there are 2 kinds of such Decompositions, Horizontal and Vertical.
Horizontal de, Decompositions are done at the same level of abstraction.
We understand the human body in terms of its digestive, respiratory, immune and
so on systems. However, we can also decompose vertically by going deeper into
the abstraction hierarchy, that is we understand the respiratory system in
terms of Lungs, Trachea, Diaphragm. The Lungs in terms of Alveoli and
gas transfer for example. We have already seen how, Acme deals with
Horizontal Decomposition in terms of components like connectors and
so on. now let's look at it's support for Vertical Decomposition.